foreign
late one night during our first year of
college my friend told me he was going
to kill himself
I did what I could do to keep him safe
and today he's alive
and he's well
tragically however
in the first 13 months of my
undergraduate experience
six other students at my school did die
by Suicide
I came to understand
that the issue of higher ed student
mental Wellness
is urgent
according to the CDC since March of 2020
one in four U.S 18 to 24 year olds have
expressed serious thoughts of suicide
a 2021 analysis performed by Harvard's
Graduate School of Education
revealed that nearly 40 percent of U.S
adults experience serious loneliness
in the preceding year
that means feeling lonely all or almost
all the time
the U.S Department of Health and Human
Services recently published data showing
that chronic loneliness is as bad for
one's physical health as smoking 15
cigarettes a day
that's to say nothing of the impact of
chronic loneliness on one's Mental
Health
looking outside of the U.S
the United Kingdom recently appointed a
minister of loneliness because this
public health issue is so dire
let's let that sink in
the United Kingdom appointed a minister
of loneliness
whether seen or unseen
people all around us are struggling
whether scene or unseen people all
around us are suffering
and the question is why
this is a question I've been exploring
for about nine years
I produced research on the silent
struggles of undergraduates
and I founded a national non-profit
mental Wellness organization that serves
higher ed students
well we still don't know all the answers
to this question of why
tonight
I want to share with you some of what we
do know
one of the many contributing elements is
a lack of what are called protective
factors
well clinicians are the only ones
qualified to intervene clinically
research has shown that any person
clinician or not
can make a life-changing difference for
someone else by promoting three
protective factors
number one non-judgment
number two
unconditional belief
and number three
dependability
put a different way it's one person that
could be me that could be you could be
you
showing another person
I don't judge you
I believe in you
and I'm there for you
but this world of done judgment this
world of unconditional belief this world
of dependability
sadly
is not the world in which we currently
live
right
how many times have you had someone say
to you don't worry I'm not judging you
and then you start talking to them and
they're literally judging you you can
see it on their face
or how about someone saying to you I
believe in you no matter what
but then time goes on and circumstances
change and turns out that unconditional
belief pretty conditional
finally
have any of you ever had someone say to
you reach out anytime don't hesitate
you know they kind of mean
I hope that person doesn't contact me
most of us have had these experiences
and in the words of the Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia's Dr Kenneth
Ginsburg
one of the leading Minds globally on the
impact of protective factors
it's not
actually about the words that we say to
each other
promoting protective factors is about
how you make a person feel
by making what many May view as just a
small shift in execution
going from saying the words I don't
judge you I believe in you I'm there for
you
to actually helping people feel the
meaning behind those words
we can help to change lives
and we can help
to save lives
reflecting back on that one night in
college
that one night with my friend
I didn't say to my friend
I don't judge you
I believe in you I'm there for you
but I tried my hardest to listen to him
with empathy
and be aware of my facial expressions
I repeatedly
shared with my friend how the world is
better for him being in it not the
person that other people wanted him to
be him
being in it
and I didn't leave my friend's side
until the next morning
when he was safely in the hands of
professionals
well I'm in no way trying to imply that
promoting protective factors is a
substitute for Crisis Intervention
it's not
what I am saying
is that whether someone is suicidal or
not suicidal
promoting protective factors can make an
important difference
yet to provide this type of support can
be tough
it can take a toll
if you've been on an airplane you're
likely familiar with the expression put
your own oxygen mask on before helping
somebody else
it's the same idea here
beyond that
everyone you and you and you and you and
you and all of us
are worthy of self-care
we deserve it simply because we are
human
with people all around us suffering
and with people all around us struggling
there's a way that each and every one of
us can make a difference literally every
day
helping to change lives and helping to
save lives
number one
we can engage in self-care
and number two
at the point at which we feel able
we can promote those protective factors
I don't judge you
I believe in you
and I'm there for you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]